au départ bur ce ne sont que des champs
à perte de vue
au beau milieu un petit village d'une
centaine d'âmes près de bar-le-duc dans
la meuse
aujourd'hui c'est un vaste terrain de
lutte entre l'état et les anti
nucléaires tout commence en 1998 cet
endroit quasi désert est choisi pour
construire le plus grand site
d'enfouissement de déchets nucléaires
d'europe
de quoi susciter dès le départ un peu
d'inquiétude
est ce que tu attends pour accor faire
de la grotte de mirabel quand tu vas te
faire aujourd'hui
j'espère que mon village à bouger quand
on aura des nouvelles habitations des
gens nouveaux cons à grandir à notre
jauge pour l'emploi dans notre secteur
on fera quand même du bien je le pense
six cents ouvriers qui travailleront
tant mieux pour nous dix années
s'écoulent dix années d'études de
laboratoire avant que le chantier ne
commence c'est l'andra l'agencé
nationale pour la gestion des déchets
radioactifs qui s'occupe de ce projet
baptisé si giroud et notre génération
qui a produit les déchets radioactifs et
qui doit s'assurer de la bonne gestion
de ces déchets on ne peut pas laisser
aux générations futures à 300-400 la
responsabilité de les gérer et se
désintéressait du problème au delà du
coût environ 25 milliards d'euros et des
polémiques sur les risques pour
l'environnement
l'inquiétude porte sur l'irréversibilité
du projet une solution présentée comme
la moins mauvaise par nicolas hulot
alors ministre de la transition
écologique pour être sincère avec vous
cette solution n'est pas entièrement
satisfaisante mais disons que c'est la
moins mauvaise et pour vous dire le fond
de ma pensée je pense qu'il va
malheureusement pas de solution miracle
un problème aussi complexe longtemps
pacifiste bon enfant la lutte
s'intensifie en 2016 plusieurs habitants
et militants antinucléaires
investissent la forêt du bois le jus
situé juste au dessus du site et la zad
vire très vite à l'affrontement
l'état déloge perquisitionnent mais sur
écoute chaque manifestation connaît son
lot de violence qui atteint son
paroxysme le 15 août 2010 est une
trentaine de blessés parmi eux
robin a le pied déchiqueté par une
grenade n'importe qui pourra tester une
grenade a fait une déclaration comme ça
si on la prend dans la tête on
effectivement donc une arme létale super
dangereuse
la grande majorité des gens ce n'est pas
au courant ces armes sont utilisées dans
ce cadre-là mur devient le symbole de la
résistance et de la résilience petit à
petit la colère se déplace plusieurs
voix s'élèvent contre les violences
policières et l'acharnement judiciaire
sept personnes soupçonnées d'avoir
dégradé un hôtel et occupé illégalement
le site sont poursuivis pour association
de malfaiteurs une infraction passible
jusqu'à dix ans de prison et 150 mille
euros d'amande
[Musique]